foreign
Jacob in Dallas what's up Jacob
hey how's it going I'm good man how
about you
uh a lot of things I don't know
surviving there you go hey sometimes
it's the best we can do man what's going
on yeah
um well
not sure
maybe if there's a right or wrong way to
ask this just jump on in don't get so
hate so much hate but uh
why do I hate my newborn so much
ah tell me about it
um what's newborn's name
Charlie Charlie boy or girl
boy okay how old
uh Saturday will be eight weeks eight
weeks all right tell me about it
um
I mean
actually let me ask you some more direct
questions because I know that's uh
let me just say this saying that that
out loud was scary right
it's the first time yeah okay you're not
crazy
and I don't think you're a bad guy good
why do I feel so bad yeah
we'll we'll walk through it and I I have
a suspicion already but we'll get there
okay but I want you to know I don't
think you're a bad guy I don't think
you're crazy okay
okay cool
so tell me about the pregnancy
um you married I mean uh yeah just we
got married actually when she was uh
basically eight months eight nine months
pregnant so oh wow okay I'm elected so
you just jump to the deep end here
yeah okay how long have y'all dating how
long were y'all
about a year and a half okay
um and how old are you
21 21 okay
um
I mean I was gonna marry her anyway so
that's kind of everybody's like for sure
you were Jacob sure you were so
um she gets pregnant and y'all get
married right before how was the
delivery
reasonably
um
that was all all good
and then you were told Publications or
anything you were told by every
old man young man everybody
in your life that this was going to be
some Magic Moment everything's going to
change in the before and the after and
this and that
and that didn't happen right
not not at all okay
and then when it doesn't happen you
almost start grasping for it like where
is it where is it where is it
and I feel like I'm trying to force it
there you go yeah
so let's go with the obvious then we're
gonna work down to some of the more
um
but I think my guess what I think it
actually is going on here
um your world has exploded right
it's crumbling tell me about it
um well not that everything was awesome
beforehand or perfect or I should it was
awesome but it wasn't perfect right
um
I don't know I mean so I had just moved
to me and my
then girlfriend now wife moved to Dallas
in 2021
um so I was 19 when I moved out here
um
and we had just gotten together at that
point but I dropped out of school
um
and we were just trying to figure figure
this out and uh got a job and I've just
been kind of working since then but I
I don't know I've super neglected being
healthy or
you know whatever especially since he's
been born
um you know
just gummy candies and pizza literally
pizza rolls every night
Diet Coke we're making fun of me Jacob
stop making fun of me hey all right so
let's let's don't blow by this you're
21.
your world just exploded
your girlfriend overnight became your
wife
faster than you anticipated
right
um what limited money you had it's
completely gone
and you're probably yeah probably in the
negative
um yeah your body feels terrible
and you haven't slept
and at the end of that rainbow is
supposed to be this life-changing
being
yeah and one thing I hear and supposed
to make all that worth it right and it's
that's what they say that's what they
say and I want to let you know the
reason I'm telling you you're not crazy
one of the most common one of the most
common conversations I have with brand
new dads behind closed doors
is
I've never poured into something I've
never given every thought every
ounce of everything I got I'm beyond
tired and other
um otherworldly tired
in this little being won't even
acknowledge me
this little being doesn't like me just
wants my wife just wants baby's mom and
I there's no psychology there's no
physiology for putting so much into this
idea of love and not getting anything
back
yeah yeah
see what I'm saying
yeah like
it was gonna be this big hole ta-da and
it's not just when you pick him up he
screams at you
just screams yes
and because you're a caring guy
and I don't I don't say this in the
pejorative way like you're just young
like you haven't you haven't had a lot
of experiences with with
kids with Messy relationships
um
it's easy to personify that well it's a
person it's easy to make that kid 22
years old
and if you hug somebody you loved and
they screamed every time and shoved you
away that would that would be
devastating
and instead of realizing this is just
like
a bundle of nerve endings that doesn't
know up from down it's you know it's
just but it's easy to say hey that's
just a person it's a being I'm your dad
make all of this other crap better
the baby just goes right
yeah for sure okay
so let's let's not blow past that
also
paternal postpartum depression is a very
real thing
okay
um
there is sometimes some men experience
an off the table falling off like a
cliff drop in their testosterone after
they have kids in fact there's some
studies about testosterone kids men who
play with their kids more more active
with their kids their testosterone will
will drop off
some after the baby is born it falls off
the map
and so everything feels like it's gone
dark like there's Shades pulled on
everything Shades pull on that that
spark used to have with your wife Shades
pull on
um the joy you have going to work the
shades pull down on this little human
who's taken everything from you
including the woman you loved and all of
your money and all of your resources and
all of your time and all of your energy
and all of your sleep and all that stuff
and it's just underwater
and then this little baby becomes the
epicenter of your
depression most men experience
depression
as rage anger
hate
okay yeah that's showing up everywhere
right you're probably although you say I
hate my in my newborn I hate my infant I
bet you are not a peach to be around to
anybody else either right
no you're not so
um I work with middle schoolers all day
holy smokes I yell at him I mean I'm a
tennis coach so yeah Jacob don't be that
coach okay listen
I never ever ever ever ever want to
diagnose somebody from this show okay
that's that would be irresponsible of of
me and all that
um I do want you
to go talk to a doctor
okay and if you've listened to the show
long enough I rarely say that I'll tell
people to go see a counselor I'll tell
people to write a letter to them former
selves and all that kind of stuff you
need to go see a doctor okay
okay
how long has this under current this
this time this uh trying to think that
Sun's nerdy this lower level how long
have you been running pretty low
um
before you moved
I I've been
I was depressed all all throughout high
school well I was severely bullied in
Middle School in high school
um and was been so I dealt with a lot of
that and then was finally feeling good
when I moved down here okay
um and then
it's all kind of just
it hit me like a ton of breaks like I I
swear this came out of nowhere you know
walking down the street and the piano
drops on your head that's exactly right
and if you get your t-tested in it um
and it shows that it fell off a cliff it
literally did you get hit by a piano and
maybe that's not it maybe that's not it
but everything you're telling me says
and you go talk to a doctor and then
you're gonna end up
there in the Dallas area which has got
some incredible resources
um
going to sit and talk to somebody
and I need you to hear me say this for a
living
and I've got a two-hour appointment this
Friday
okay
you're not broken you're not weird
you're not a coward I would say the
broken cowardly thing to do is just to
keep plowing forward
it's so tempting I know it is and then
you become like every other man in
America
overweight exhausted frustrated doesn't
like their family their family doesn't
like them
their face buried in their phone or
their face buried in some
pornography on their laptop like you see
what I'm saying I don't I don't want
that life for you
I don't want it either okay
so you're not crazy you're not broken
there's not quote unquote something
wrong with you
but your body's struggling right now and
that's all right
freak for for
your sake for this kid's sake for your
wife's sake
will you make a call will you go see
somebody
I want yeah
yeah let me say it this way and what I'm
going to say is it's not fair and I
would say it a little more gently if we
were meeting in person but I need to be
sensationalist for this show okay
yeah
um
if you don't make a call you are
choosing to remain Where You Are
okay don't make that choice
you're worth more than that choice
it says little Charlie
so is your new wife Fair
okay is it I can't solve this over the
radio and I can't solve it at all it's
gonna be it's gonna be up to you to do
the work does it give you any peace
to know that there's this is not
uncommon that you're not defective and
messed up in a psychopath
yeah okay it does I mean yeah it does
okay
do you ever have any thoughts of hurting
this kid
crying at 3 30 in the morning probably
just a
I might just drop you yeah and walk into
the room and go back to sleep yep
go see somebody okay
and
don't read the YouTube comments on this
one okay
people are cruel people are cruel
hey will you do me a favor will you call
me after you talk to a doctor I'd love
to hear
um they run some blood tests on you and
they sit with you for a bit I'd love to
hear what they have to say but and by
the way when you go be a hundred percent
honest
um because you hedged even a little bit
with me which I understand we're on the
radio and all that but be a hundred
percent honest okay
you're not crazy they're not gonna lock
you up
yeah and you've had that thought too
haven't you
yeah yes
yeah you get real dark thoughts just
postpartum you get real dark thoughts
that get loopy on you you try to solve
them and then you start imagining all
kinds of End of Time stuff and wow
it's your body trying to take care of
you man it's got a little sideways let's
go sit with the doctor
and then you'll end up having to sit
with some other people probably in a
group of some sort possibly with a
counselor great and it's awesome and
while you're there
you can be able to exercise some of
those demons from middle school in those
Looney Tune Middle School brats
were brutal to you
and that low-level grind you've been
doing since you were in college and
Beyond
listen
you're worth so much man
make that choice
for an exciting adventure of a peaceful
life